need motivation watch the top ten would
believe nation
what's that believe nation it seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from being in a drug rehab center at age
25 to five years after becoming a
millionaire and today owning over half a
billion dollars in real estate
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top ten roses success vol 10 also if
you want to know what grant and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link to join is in the description below
you have to go build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get known I've been here five years
you guys don't know me you know what I
didn't let you know me if you don't know
me you won't follow me right or wrong so
my job is to make sure I'm known today
today it's easier than it's ever been
before that's why I'm a guy that's using
social media to get known
takes courage to stand up here it takes
courage to get known it takes courage to
build a brand it takes courage to build
a YouTube channel and an Instagram and a
Facebook I'm 60 years old I don't know
anything about Instagram except that I
got 900,000 people that follow me every
day like a religion
you asked what church they go to I go to
the Church of Grant Cardone okay what's
my name my name is Grant Cardone what's
my name my name cuz you didn't know this
is for the people that didn't know my
name is Grant Cardone let me hear it
okay my job my job my first job your
first job is to make sure people know
your damn name because if they don't
know your name they I don't care what
you sell you're a nurse you work at
McDonald's you're a bellman I don't care
what you do you're parking cars it don't
matter if I don't know who you are it
doesn't matter how good you are how
clean you are okay it doesn't matter
your values don't matter nothing matters
if I don't know you rule number two
push into everything so don't believe in
this concept about balancing it's not
life I've never people to talk about it
don't have don't have the very thing
that's trying to get over there so
simply balancing something you're under
stress I think so totally totally so if
you just like what I do is I just push
into everything right I push into
everything as hard as I can and again
the goal is life it's not the business
it's my life right business is part of
my life so having fun is part of my life
my spiritual part is part of my life so
I'm gonna push everything into that
thing that I'm working on the 10x the
10x thing was about
I'm pushing like if it's if it's in the
business I'm gonna push as hard as I can
on that and my kids are with me
my wife's with me she there with me so
they're there they're having the
experience of this push then we turn
around we push over here oh we want to
help charities out and we push 10x into
that direction well it's just it's it
just blows out the edges of the life
right so that we get to have a bigger
experience as opposed to okay now I need
to put this here and manage this part
right now
which means when I'm doing this when I'm
finding time just for my kids I'm
abandoning all these other things and my
life gets smaller rule number three take
action all the commitment stuff oh you
got to be committed all you got to be
committed we're always talking to my
trainer about tisza
you gotta be committed yep treat this
there's only one thing you really have
to do it it's a commitments not gonna
come until you do this other thing the
thing that has got me through everything
got me to where I'm at today the thing
that changed everything was me just
taking action just doing it I mean I
know that's that old Nike saying right
just do it and even if you don't feel
like it even if you're not committed
even if you're not getting any gains
even if you're not winning I talked
about this in the rules of success show
up just take action make the call knock
on the door
send out the email bug people if you
have to you know until you get good and
it doesn't sound like bugging anymore
it's just the professional knows how to
bug people without bugging them so look
just take action even if you don't feel
like it
rule number four get the money honey is
so simple okay
anybody got a hundred dollar bill give
me a hundred dollars to give this man a
big hand for having some money okay I
just had an idea I said I wonder ain't
got any money um I had an idea now I'm
going to teach you a lesson right now
that'll make you rich if you freaking
get it okay number one I want some money
number two I need to ask somebody if
they got a hundred number three I need
to get the money it's no more
complicated than that
I didn't go manufacture something I
didn't build a business plan I didn't
create a product I had an idea the the
link of time between your idea and the
money will determine whether or not
you're successful the length of time
between the idea and the monetization
big word for get the money the the
distance between the idea and the money
will determine whether you take off or
not rule number five don't make excuses
why do we make so many excuses I think
that we are like excuses making machines
it's like if I miss a deal we do a lot
of real estate deals so if I miss a deal
I'm always going to what did I do wrong
in that deal first response for me is
what did I do wrong with that deal then
they didn't pick me mm-hmm what did I do
wrong that I didn't get that deal what
did we do wrong that we didn't hit our
number they're like I'm never saying
it's not blaming somebody well I don't
have control when I'm like I want
control so even if they are to blame
right I want control I'm not gonna
assign you blame if you hit my car I'm
gonna get my said what did I do wrong
what did I do that allowed you to hit my
car hmm I did something so even in the
most dumb dumb like III ended up in a
lawsuit where a guy basically found
something sued me for it I didn't do
anything to this dude my immediate
response was what did I do to create
that frivolous
situation he was a criminal total
criminal sued me for 60 million bucks he
just sued me because he he thought he
could get something running but but I
did something and the reason I want to
assume that what the cause I want to be
the cause point is because if I assume
that position even though I didn't
really do anything then I can control
what I did I can't control what another
person does but I can spend time and
energy to control them what I do rule
number six think wealthy company is only
as great as the driver is number two
does the dude have a bunch of fuel you
know a fuel this see this plane right
here this planes no good no matter how
good this plane is if there's no fuel
plane no good playing don't go anyplace
without fuel these it as a company I
know guys that have great companies but
they're out of fuel they're just not
they're not going to use it their
drivers they were drivers they used to
drive
they got fuel in the tank but three they
won't use it they're not going to press
because somebody's on their neck right
now saying conserve your money a lot of
rich people this happens to a lot of
rich people people get rich they go from
the middle to rich and never get wealthy
move the wealthy it becomes impossible
to get wealthy like the Rockefellers or
the people that we're talking about the
DuPont's the Morgans the the Vanderbilts
because because their car down the cod
notes because they get satisfied with
wealthy I'm sorry with rich and they
never get wealthy wealthy is
generational money grant died I
guarantee my grandkids will be talking
about me that is a bama right there dude
there's it that dude that dude dude then
you goddamn okay that and then the
number four dude you got to have a
future like the future I'm interested in
and by the way I'm gonna go back to the
New World Order boys and girls that the
Illuminati the Masons whoever they are
these people think about futures you
guys don't they're thinking about
generations that's what the Japanese do
the Japanese they think about future
generations there's nothing about right
now how about the Muslims they're
thinking about lifetimes from now rule
number seven don't think small how many
heard this before people buy from people
they like no no people buy from people
they know okay if you take a notes
people buy from people they know period
they don't buy the best product they
don't buy the cheapest product people
buy from people they know because if you
don't know me trust will not happen
that's why I rolled up on Daymond and
said hey how about I put you in the
plane and I fly you to Vegas same dudes
telling me I was stupid buying a plane I
said dude come with
what's wrong with you man you spent too
much time on a street corner selling
hats that bird that bird that bird is
what got me in front of you DJ little
man oh yeah yeah you're right man and
then he says no I'd have gone with you
anyway you would not have got on JetBlue
with me don't laugh man I know you the
people sharp but don't lie look what am
i call you hey Damon I bought a ticket
for us on Southwest you want to fly to
Vegas with me and we can eat peanuts he
wouldn't go me huh me agree he would not
have gone with me come on man he might
be the people jumping in stupid he's
like hey I ain't doing that
right around he said to me what's the
fuel in that jet cause I said bro you
thinking small bro
he's like what do you mean what's it
cost what's the damn fuel in the jet
cost I said I don't know why don't you
know I said because the jet ain't no
good without fuel rule number eight
master communication I think the the
idea of not going to endorse you know
talking to people yeah like these are
the skills that are not taught in the
schools this is why it goes back to your
question about the school system failing
the bake that the the required skills I
need a client like if you simplify the
thing that people like about what we do
is we simplify the business process
mmm-hmm
I need to make a contact how can I do
that like how can I just simply if I'm
doing if I'm a cameraman and I want more
work you know how do I knock on the door
or make a phone call get in front of
someone so hard impress them
you know if I go to Harrods right here
I'll see how many people don't have that
skill I walk in that I don't even get a
Hello you know I don't get hello how you
doing great to have you appreciate you
being here so nice of you to drop by
thanks for coming into Cartier I mean
it's a three million dollar ring over
there I went in there the other day I
can't even get anybody to show me
anything I'm like how much is the ring
you know they kind of look at me right
can you show it to me do you mind
showing it to me he showed it to me tell
me how much it was and I'll leave you
didn't show me a second ring a third
ring unfortunately so those are the
skills that people need right how do i
how do i interact with people
communicate yeah
rule number nine multiply the middle
class adds and subtracts and clearly the
middle class never figured out how to do
with the super-wealthy do like it's
almost like hundreds of millions of
people in America
stop math that adding and subtracting
and never got to the multiplication part
yeah because the super-wealthy of
multipliers oh by the way time energy
and money they multiply all of them
they're like I have time I want to make
more time how do I do that you learned
how to add you learned how to subtract
but that's not what the Rothschilds did
that's not what the Rockefellers did
that's not what the DuPont's did take
multipliers their multipliers and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is you can afford
anything we can't afford that how many
you told your kids with that before we
can't do that bike we can't buy the bike
right you told your kids that cuz you
were told that right we don't tell our
kids that how many of you were told this
kids be careful that's why you guys
think so much you got yet Dave Ramsey on
TV saying total freedom comes from not
having debt ok you got you you flip
channels and you go to Suze you can't
afford that
ok I'm gonna tell you do you can afford
anything
[Music]
hey debts not your problem okay I got
four four I got I probably got 500
million dollars worth of debt today 500
million I wish it was five billion
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from grant on how to help people that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these three questions in the
comments below here we go
question number one what excuses are you
going to let go of number two what
action are you going to take today and
number three how are you going to get
known this week
how did you get into the training
business I had a passion for for helping
people when I was a young salesperson
and I found that when I had struggles
when I had droughts cold spells where I
wasn't selling anything
if I would help if I would help somebody
else it it always broke my drought so
for some reason it was easier when I
wasn't doing well to help somebody else
to help someone else and it seemed to
break my is I don't know why I worked
like that but maybe it's one of those
golden rules about help people you know
the more you give the more you get and
so it always broke this cold moment I
had when I would reach out and help
another person raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that
passion not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's suppose to mean
if you want more grant check of the
video we did on his ultimate guide to
becoming a millionaire the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
while many of you may say they have
millions enough trust me if you come up
short in your goals set them higher